okay okay matches okay [ __ ] it's time
for another quest x 13 attack of the
infiltrator okay and it's your boy
psychobabble here of course with Kanye
right here very happy is new albums
about the drop okay it's about the
chopped like bowtie like that Kamber
that you know and I'm sayin you know
what i was saying i don't even need to
explain further okay oh it is this and
[ __ ] [ __ ] dog eyes shut hello police
cyber I
Oh is tongue looks like my legs
the secret to fighting is this is keep
following the chicken or something
happen Jana I like yay yeah I always
drink their blood it's gonna it's more
like a fetish of a survival instinct you
know what I'm saying give it doc me baby
give me that talk mate yeah so many
people ask me that like psycho what is
with you and dog mate and I say you know
it's the only thing a cool little paw
down
that's I'm in a [ __ ] a step back watch
a dog man ok so just shoot me [ __ ] a I
get out their head yeah [ __ ] ok corral
for the game Erica time the [ __ ] is back
in the hall
oh [ __ ] is shedding right yeah yeah
thanks ow ow [ __ ] hey this guy's like am
a [ __ ] wet wax I got a vast impacts
ur a step back tough flux a cherry bomb
all i know is i'm getting [ __ ] up with
all this like radiation like seriously
[ __ ] up me [ __ ] quicksave again
this is just not God like I don't know
I'd also tell you sorry but I'm getting
[ __ ] up ok oh why did I mention that
my selfies hope it to you so talk ok get
10 now shut do I have what I like
dynamite I could [ __ ] through yes
how do I have like so little chance of
hitting him [ __ ] is going on here oh
shut nut huh you know good you know this
is my dream job just like fighting dogs
with revolvers oh great okay good and
the [ __ ] is my
I think I just [ __ ] hurts will shoot
him yeah this [ __ ] up okay um Chinese
s where's the cannibal work there we go
how do you any either Eddie eat it I'm
here to eat this ok
shave this
okay definitely not doing well I'll be
honest uh yeah I guess all's well son
well yeah okay I just know it we're [ __ ]
here I just know it's plenty of [ __ ] are
you okay just just that something else
out of and I'll be happy to fight it
it's just you know I like what it takes
someone from like a Malo I shouldn't
pistol at me great great great great
okay great oh I thought what [ __ ]
flying egg [ __ ] erotic I can't stay ok
it like check the level ok tonic time to
eat this tale you know I I love tales
like what else am I gonna say like it's
all I think about life it's getting to
hell ok yeah because nothing
and
okay now they put your thing in all this
is to find some [ __ ] hell jay says no
[ __ ] believe it out these days good
okay
yes oh you take that beer paper where
you [ __ ] that Ted even know what is this
duct tape fork at that thank you thank
you I got the cat okay okay
and
Laser piss off man
hello sir
need some [ __ ] help babe why does
that cat
uh-huh can I wear all these gloves what
happened I [ __ ] liar by this protec
loves
oh there's a health regeneration what
the flying [ __ ] how long did I [ __ ]
have that [ __ ]
God God you know it's it's always a good
son it just bleh okay
what is that I ranches yeah this is all
good and dandy but and I like I'd like
some [ __ ] hell that's all not thank
you damn it's bright outside oh hello
that Loretta my just shat here you know
if I wanted [ __ ] I would show on the
floor left there's an erase [ __ ] is that
[ __ ] down there now
it's a second click hitch and the case
I'll activate I can't
okay okay a lot of fans
give me some [ __ ] out
she's awfully there's a string here like
okay what's that right here hello sir
hello sir
hey I'd get that [ __ ] so there wonder
gloat no thank you
oh I have to [ __ ] equip that the
stealth suit
okay okay do I have anything I can equip
know
same thing okay
okay well it telling me to go this way
so let's who happens [ __ ] was that
Oh
25
they dumped us get get
hello it's nice to meet you who can I
hide you from today I don't know leave
me out of stimpacks take Dan your ad
pays look a [ __ ] about there let me know
on medics ok ma'am you wanna eat thats
not good tell me everything you mean
he's taking me up but back to [ __ ]
try it out on you
ok
alright i guess he's just like in there
alright I guess it's just how it is yes
please unlock the door the data
collection online please use the
terminal below to begin user
synchronization
same old [ __ ] anything I can do to get
health real quick that's good Oh steady
how [ __ ] still red paste look I'll
drink that [ __ ] wait a sec we check all
the [ __ ] that's in here real quick Mike
Evie wants a [ __ ] administration
observation area that's hard you should
check the secrets do anything
cigarettes now okay don't do [ __ ] i just
said rock hard what the [ __ ] is down
there it's [ __ ] frightening I don't
even want to know what the [ __ ] down
there
something go like crazy around here
technician can I get easier
Jesus
ok
oh my god yes
now what the [ __ ] is down there that is
like so important
no that's a wrap okay okay [ __ ] out you
gotta do it you know you only let Watts
Anna yeah so much like old times but you
know for most by you know that once
oh they gave you a [ __ ] ton of stuff
that's nice
award safe is empty
hello sir
the [ __ ]
okay don't shoot the questors
nice stuff here alone okay but it's it's
whatever Jesus is gonna be [ __ ] like
gum Charlotte not hello sir may I know
what's about to go down we're not going
to be friends in a second
this is the basic stuff test the robots
will be looking for us or we won't let
them find us
hmm
[ __ ]
too bad we were spotted by robots if you
go back to the terminal to restart the
test I won't mess up again
ok [ __ ] a
can I like
well they're like a way to
it should be easy as long as I don't
screw up again starting combat just
kidding
a chef
I don't think I can just I think it's
just that I can't step on anything cuz
I'll make like noise [ __ ] now they're
going to share his officer over there
he's like what the [ __ ] is that
test data processed firmware updated to
version 1.1 stamping sensors online oh
great well thanks for watching gosh
thank you
you